thank you
welcome back to another careful boys
where we are very careful boys and today
we are talking about
women having guy friends women I like it
is it chill is it do you guys feel
threatened
if your lady has guy friends I did in
the 90s I was hello 90s what were you
like 12 earlier late 90s late 90s I was
16. stick that phallic in your mouth
somebody make that a meme please no no
please don't well there's there's some
truth to it right because as guys we all
know
that most of her guy friends are trying
to steal bone that's correct 100 that's
a absolute fact it's a fact of of the
matter
and it's duh because we're the same way
that's why we know it's like yeah you
should stay away yeah yeah
but also the older you get the more you
like
so when is it acceptable what
circumstance it's not acceptable it's
never okay punishable but death yeah I
think so it's a relative just let me put
this on my my girl's got a couple guy
friends that are like really really
close friends but they're all gay and
I'm like we should still we should still
like do and you're like
group and they're married
but like or like you've known this
person for like decades before like
before like someone came into the
picture and the nature of the hangout
yeah Define friendship Define friendship
like you're not hanging out going over
to his house late at night watching a
movie yeah you know Netflix and chill
like with your guy friend that seems a
little like you're just doing like a
vacation together Yeah Yeah by
yourselves yeah yeah that's fine if
she's laughing harder his jokes than
mine yeah not down if she's like I'm
just sucking his dick what's your
problem big deal his dick fell in my
mouth
jeez I escalated quickly yeah great I do
okay so we were just having this chat
before like the cameras rolled right but
I started to when I was super jealous in
high school after that I was like you
know what
I rather just get cheated on if she's
gonna do that why am I holding yeah no
you're right about that that is a great
control if she's gonna be a cheater
anyway so then that's gonna happen I
went the other way and I was so like
just [ __ ] hang out because I wanted
to see who they really were like as a
person and then so so set traps from
there yeah I set so many traps I would
be like yo I'll get the most handsome
friend that I got and be like yo try to
[ __ ] brains out go ahead go ahead now
they're married and now no but then
worked it worked yeah they got they're
happily married I totally hooked them up
Joe's just a Matchmaker that's it she's
a Good Luck Chuck but then if I create
that recipe it also was liberating for
me because then I wasn't worried I
wasn't feeling like oh my God where's
she at how come she's not calling oh my
God that is so sexy oh she didn't text
back it's been five minutes you know hot
hot Behavior right you just I just care
about her safety yeah so make sure she's
okay that's it yeah where are you where
the [ __ ] are you where are you [ __ ] why
are you [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah I'm worried
about you in terms of examples it is it
is super true like uh when they say that
oh that's just guys being insecure when
they act like that and I will say it is
true because back in my early days of
dating when I used to trip about that
[ __ ] about girls I that I was dating
having guy friends I would trip because
I wasn't super confident in myself and I
I wouldn't want her to discover really
great qualities about a guy that I don't
have and then I would go
um fun go have fun with your cool friend
so true throw a football you know just
whatever the [ __ ] and then as you get
older and you figure out the things you
like about yourself that nobody else has
then you just go okay this is what this
Shop sells and if this isn't what you
want that's you're on you you know
whatever and wouldn't you want to know
early on in the relationship if they're
gonna do it you want to know very early
on before you invest more time so you're
gonna spend all this time controlling
her for like four years and then she
never had the opportunity to cheat on
you because you kept controlling her
yeah but also it is also a bad move to
just be too passive that it's like you
don't even [ __ ] register anything it
is still like a real thing to be like
hey that guy's kind of crossing the line
like your girl's still going to want to
know where you stand on things like that
because that's also unsexy when you just
really don't give a [ __ ]
I'm all too Carefree right then it's
just like okay oh go ahead go ahead I'm
gonna hang out with Elizabeth later
anyways no yeah that's a cool guy right
yeah that's a cool guy told me early on
in our relationship she [ __ ] loved it
when um we were at like her birthday and
we used to do like karaoke at Brass
Monkey in LA and there was a cat who's
there and he's like putting his hand on
her back and I was like like on like the
small of her back you know what he's
talking to her I was like hey dude you
don't gotta touch your back yeah and
that was it and Nick he was like I
[ __ ] love that
yeah why was he doing that in front of
you I don't think he knew I was
territorial boyfriend yeah sometimes
they don't know yeah that's how people
say you know what I would do though
um I would just see how she would handle
the situation that and then you beat off
to it
I would jack off while he's touching her
and I go
to see if she would respect the
relationship well not only just herself
but also the relationship that you guys
have that's true also I want to see what
her threshold is for like
not violence but like how hard she can
fight back or if she doesn't like a
situation does she say something is she
gonna be passive or not right yeah Nikki
particularly was with a guy previously
who was who would laugh at guys hitting
on her and he like loved it and she
hated that like she she was like [ __ ]
defend me do something like this guy's
like touching me and [ __ ] and so that's
why he would laugh but if you knew that
about her I didn't know okay but that
helped if you did because then now you
know how to approach the situation no it
helps that he didn't know and he still
approached the right way it's like ah
okay double credit that's just how I
handle [ __ ] because I'm like you're
Crossing line dude what the [ __ ] she
doesn't want you touching her back yeah
like girls don't like that there's still
gonna be a scale of comfort you know
yeah that makes sense but then you know
what else sucks this also is a thing
like the friend who let's say your girl
does have a guy friend and it does get a
little bit weird and you're kind of like
hey let's uh let's not so much huh and
then that guy gets mad oh that's the
best and then yeah exactly and he's like
don't let your dude control who your
friends are that dude needs to go that
guy can't fight guys out that guy can't
wait to cut the line and then control
him oh that that dude had
happens from the very beginning exactly
exactly that's the only reason why he's
there right because I've had friends
that are girls that will end up with a
dude that maybe doesn't know me and then
so I I will respectfully be like cool
like that's fine I don't give a [ __ ]
like Thrive and then whenever you're
ready like what's up how you doing let's
catch up but I'm not like yo you need to
start hanging out with me more because
ever since he came along you're very
like rare that is so [ __ ] it's actually
crazy but guys do that [ __ ] too so that
makes it crazy I've also been uh I've
been in like two former relationships as
well where uh when I'd be like hanging
out with that that girl
um they would have a close guy friend
that they've known for a while that's
like platonic or whatever and I'll call
it out like that guy's so into you while
I'm dating that girl oh yeah right and
she's like what are you talking just
super nice and they are oblivious though
they really are and then when we stopped
dating it's like they eventually get
together and I'm like
so is it a girl is she actually
oblivious you know or she's just got a
plan B yeah I think she's I think for
him it's a down payment on a future [ __ ]
session yeah
so when when he's when you break up with
her he's like saying it's okay and then
he bones absolutely as a rebound yeah I
was born yesterday and that's a that's
such a frequently occurring thing too
that happened with one of my exes I
remember like we were kind of at the
tail end of our relationship and we went
out to this like club and then this dude
who was like she's like oh you're gonna
meet this guy he's really cool he's like
a writer he writes yeah I was like oh
[ __ ] grang that's the red flag right
there yeah exactly that's that's the
number one red flag it's like there's a
physical familiarity that you were not
like privy to you're like whoa okay you
guys got [ __ ] things already huh and
then uh I remember this one thing like
she uh she was like wearing some hat or
whatever this sounds so stupid she was
wearing some hat and then he like took
it over her head and then he started
like dancing like and I was like that is
a dumb [ __ ] [ __ ] that's that's one of
the flirtiest moves ever
I never said anything I wasn't like this
is like I just took a mental note after
we broke up first dude she [ __ ] was
that guy oh so she's been into um you
think I think you could just tell like
who's kind of meeting the threshold of
like he I know that he's in the radar of
like he he's smiled in a different
folder than everyone else and also women
we know we we absolutely know it's just
I think some women just play dumb
because they like the attention from all
fronts absolutely you are selling them
out yeah sorry
to be fair guys do too though right you
know what I mean
um I just think women usually have more
options
are infinitely more options yeah for
sure yeah I mean
um I think it's up to us too like I I
remember situations where if I do start
feeling feelings then I pull back in the
friendship or anything because I'm like
oh if I can't be honest about my
intentions here and she's in a
relationship and I I also don't want to
create a situation where I'm like
pouring my heart out to her and then now
she's in the middle of like well [ __ ] I
like you too but I'm in this
relationship I'm like that's too
complicated so I'm like let me just exit
regardless of what she thinks is going
on like I think that's the best
because we don't have to main we don't
this friendship is like to me it's like
until you're married with someone like
there's there's no real social
obligations anywhere it's just like it's
just moments that you share with humans
right so then it's like yeah like
whatever happens in the future cool but
if I care about this person then it's
probably not a good idea to pursue them
selfishly when they're in a situation
especially if they think I'm a friend
so then I think for guys too you need to
just like control how you feel in that
situation and how to get out of it if
you need or just to not put yourself in
that that's right like you can't help
what you're into you know what I'm
saying so even if you're not
strategically trying to be like I'm
Gonna Keep options open I'm gonna Scout
you know what I mean even if you're not
trying to you might have people in your
circle that you're like I just happen to
be attracted to that type of person yeah
like for me myself included like um once
I got into a committed relationship I
subconsciously or consciously had to cut
a couple friendships and really like hot
homies
homies straight up because you know what
I mean because it's playing with fire
yeah the [ __ ] you were putting on
layaway dude yeah like why even put
yourself in that depending downloads
yeah all the down payments you got to
get my money back you're putting monthly
payments into that [ __ ] and now it's
time to go and they're just collected
they don't want the idol
the ones you added to cart the girl so
so one exam Apple I have is like I did
have a platonic friendship with a girl
and she was probably into me I don't
know
um because
she just had a breakup
and like maybe we flirted or talked her
in class I forgot what I did but she
wanted to thank me with some cookies
that she baked right and her
ex-boyfriend saw that [ __ ] and then he
went on he had her password for her
[ __ ] AIM account he pretended to be
her talk to me and said hey I'm stranded
at this party there's a lot of weird
guys I need to get help so I pulled up
took my mom's car went to go pick her up
and then him and his boys came out
[ __ ] bashed the car while I was in
the ride pepper sprayed me whoa yeah so
I was like I was like you son of a
[ __ ] jealous little [ __ ] dude like
you are such a jealous little [ __ ] and
you had to wear masks like nobody could
fight me they were just I was like
that's something and there's no cookies
yeah yeah
it's just the dough and those cookies
were so salty dude oh really how do you
get salty cooking no she she baked them
and it wasn't that good she put two she
was crying while she was netting the
dough that's how they get salty that's a
red flag can you be in a can you
authentically have a platonic
relationship with the opposite sex if
you find them attractive no no hell no
it's playing with fire it's playing with
fire I think it's it's rare but I think
you can do it what's a friendship but
here's my whole definition for this yeah
go go for it I think I think it's if you
develop some kind of odd paternal like
like sibling type of friendship well you
want to [ __ ] them
you can objectively say oh this person's
attractive but not want to pursue that
but but it doesn't always have to always
be like uh sexual either because you can
emotionally you know kind of build it
build a connection that's my thing yeah
it takes you away from your your
personal relationship as well you know
so people love to do this meme of like
yes of course you can be friends and
then they like to roast me about this
because I've never believed this [ __ ]
but it's because you're not a real
friend with this person if you can't go
hang out alone you can't [ __ ] trust
yourself around them you're not being
their real friend you're more of an
acquaintance I think if you're attracted
yeah if you're attracted you have other
that's not I don't want to [ __ ] my
friends
you're not my friend but he still want
to [ __ ] you though so yeah you're so
Ryan's my friend right like do I wanna
like do I have a secret idea of like
[ __ ] of like [ __ ] Rhymes that's so
true you know what I'm saying because
like I would hope that I would never
[ __ ] you dude I would never [ __ ] you why
does that hurt even though it's straight
you can't be comfortable alone that's
not a true friendship because if you're
still imagining railing the [ __ ] out of
them while you're talking about like
games or whatever that's not a
friendship no yeah I believe that
because when I hang out with you Ryan
and we're talking about cars I'm not
imagining you wrapping your mouth around
my dick
talking about we're talking about the
office of sex though so you're saying if
for the opposite sex you're in a
friendship but you objectively find them
attractive or you think they're
attractive you can say okay yeah you're
an attractive human being but have no
motive to to pursue that you can't have
a friendship with them I think I think
so I think for most I think so for most
most guys right
the difficulty here and this is why a
lot of guys are like you shouldn't be
friends with that guy's into you is
because even if he hasn't he has no
intentions of being with you
romantically they still would sleep with
you if they have that opportunity so
it's the drug part of it it's the male
sexual desired drug part that they will
ruin that friendship because that power
is so strong and that self-control might
not be stronger he's not a hungry Rosie
boa he just ate you can oh you're the
little mouse you can hang out with the
rosie boat he just ate you're totally
fine
his instinct is to eat yeah shut the
[ __ ] up what kind of friendship is it if
you're if you're the mouse and he's the
snake that's all I'm saying like it's
not really a real friendship because you
can't be alone with them because he will
eat you yeah okay what if it's a what if
this is like a work Dynamic friendship
relationship that's fine situation
that's fine but but what Steve is
talking about is like best friends or
like tight circle like you can't have
enough authentic friendship when it's
not real when you're thinking about
railing Ryan in the back I think
regardless damn it it just goes well
work or not work I think that it's not
that easy by the way you can't just do
it yeah you're a little [ __ ] he's just
rail me when I whatever
two-party consent you'd give it up dude
give it up what kind of friend are you
anyway then you would have thrown
something to your voice all I'm saying
all I'm saying is regardless of the work
environment thing I think the variables
you said if you're attracted to them
like regardless work or not work it's
like if you're attracted to that person
in that friendship like I I don't think
it can be super platonic I'm not gonna
make it because like hypothetically yeah
you're saying you wouldn't [ __ ] [ __ ]
you all right
you would still [ __ ] you oh [ __ ] you
okay I'll dominate your [ __ ] I'm down
to be [ __ ] by you all right you know
why because he's an alpha that's what
I'm saying thank you
dominate yeah but after a bus watch he's
gonna be the Alpha and the cuddling all
right so hey hey all I'm saying all I'm
saying is like let's say let's say you
uh are uh in a committed relationship
and then you have an opposite sex uh
relation platonic friendship uh that you
are attracted to and you never cross
that line but maybe one day in a long
time this relationship something that's
like that person [ __ ] up a little bit
or you're piss at them or like maybe
they kind of cross the line in something
else and you feel [ __ ] vengeful or
anything or you just go and get drunk
with the person that you're comfortable
with you know what I mean there's so
many variables that can like lead you're
playing with fire yeah yeah you're
putting yourself in that scenario yeah
so it's like not even being in that
situation is the only guarantee as long
what's the snake fed give me a [ __ ]
break then like you know I mean that's
it's a snake thing because also it's
like
I'm a reptile guy I am an alphabet
because you do I mean you know like I
think also a reptile dysfunction another
part of being an alpha male yeah thank
you another part of it like that's a
fellow Alpha as a fellow alpha male I
think the duty of an alpha male is also
to be able to control your desires so
like what separates man from boy is like
having your impulses controlled right
but then when you are in these
situations it is much harder to control
because when I'm hanging out with Ryan
and I'm thinking about sticking his
ankles behind his back I'm not gonna
disease yeah yeah yeah we can't focus on
golfing yeah yeah Joe's just biting his
lips all the time because I'm just I
can't I and I and that's like I gotta
get her out of that situation you better
look like I'm just spreading my cheeks
all day in front of you guys you're just
you have a [ __ ] Vibe what's giving
you that you're like this close to being
fired already I seem ready Luke every
single time you like shave your facial
hair too it's like damn I want to
[ __ ] eat you up dude look at his face
right now a new Ryan every time howdy
[ __ ] lips away he's like come on
there's a little hair is a little
[ __ ] hey man as an example though I
do I do have I think attraction is the
key right there because like I have
friends that are girls that I've not
crossed the line with them either no
because you want to vomit thinking about
sleeping with them yeah but but do you
think they're Attractive people
absolutely okay but you're not attracted
to them I'm proud of their beauty and I
will represent it and be like oh like
when she got married I like wanted to
cry oh she looks so pretty in her dress
but I'm not like dress looks so pretty
the dress is pretty the dress is better
you know who your pretty friends are you
know what I mean like it's like it's
like how could you be a married casting
agent then and not objectively know
who's hot that doesn't make sense but
it's not just hotness I think the key is
attractive it's attraction it's
attraction yeah because if you're like
attracted and attractive yeah that's
true exactly also your uh your
significant other is like super shallow
but your significant other needs to be
like the highest Echelon of what you're
attracted to as well so even if you're
like your platonic friend is like really
attractive as long as your partner is
more attractive to you to you then
you're in a more safe place yeah more
safe but is it though because like
so like I think there's at least for me
there's never been a time where I didn't
want to [ __ ] everything I saw yeah
interesting so like
no I'm just glad because that doesn't go
over here quick
that's why I feel better about that
answer oh it's not just me because it's
not me it's getting hot in here dude
that's when we hear the deadbolt lock
and rock and roll music starts to put it
we can't get the [ __ ] up
it's like do you think he's still alive
I don't know but we had to get that out
of there but at least he's mad you have
a predicate to that subject well okay so
no just end the video
oh 21 minutes we all think differently
right or we have a different experience
in my case
I think the the sexual part of it isn't
always emotional and like I just want to
have sex with a nice looking creature
that's all it is and there's no I mean
there's nothing and then like that
intensity though not a creature it's
like always there
it's it doesn't matter how beautiful how
I love how much I care about the person
I'm with the only thing that prevents me
is how my partner would feel like that
would kill me if I break her or whether
or not I would let you no
if I want you I'm getting it that's a
[ __ ] hell
foreign